The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
introduces you to a Hyrule that is truly
seamless we're simply moving from one
place to another begins to create what
may be the adventure of a lifetime and
not only is this new world vast but it
feels alive it teems with adventure
throughout links quest Hyrule will be a
resource an ally an enemy and always a
place for discovery and wonder this is
easily one of the biggest experiences
ever created by Nintendo and today
you're going to get a close-up look the
portion of the game we're highlighting
at e3 a wide-ranging plateau may seem
huge in fact no one here this week will
be able to explore all of it but even
then that plateau is only a tiny
fraction of the full game map will be
devoting almost this full first day of
Nintendo treehouse live coverage to just
this one environment then in the future
you'll learn more about the story the
characters and the ways in which the
boundaries of all previous Zelda titles
are being broken but in the end full
understanding and full immersion will
only come when you experience it for
yourself however before we show you this
biggest adventure for wii u + NX we're
going to show you the biggest new
adventure coming up for nintendo 3ds as
you've heard there are two new core
pokemon titles on the way on November
eighteenth Pokemon Sun and Pokemon moon
as always you'll pick which new starter
Pokemon to partner with but which one to
choose exactly what kind of battling
awaits you and what does the new a lolla
region have in store for players well we
figured there was no one better equipped
to answer those questions than the two
key developers of the game
itself producer junichi Masuda and
director Shigeru amore of Game Freak so
before we devote the rest of the day to
the legend of zelda I'm going to turn it
over to the treehouse team along with
mr. Matsuda and mr. amore to show you
what it's like to start as a pokemon
trainer in the first-ever live gameplay
demonstration of Pokemon Sun and Pokemon
moon so let's jump in take it away Sam
and Terry thanks Reggie and thanks to
everyone watching for tuning in and
joining us for another Nintendo
treehouse live at e3 we're really
excited to get started so as Reggie
mentioned i'm sam from nintendo and
joining me up here I've got Terry from
Nintendo and my colleague David from tpc
I and we've also got our very special
guests masuda son and a morir son from
Game Freak who are joining us to chat
about come on son and Pokemon moon now
Pokemon fans already know that you guys
have a very long history of working with
the Pokemon franchise but you tell our
viewers a little bit more about what you
guys are doing specifically with Pokemon
Sun and Pokemon moon oops David Oman oh
[ __ ] him on okay honey macaca at this
we're gonna mock Nicki on that is gonna
come quella porque Monsanto for came on
Monday ocarina Satoshi tomorrow muska
hey so listen a no photo cheap ok manga
no niji soon enter foto de mo Cara's
Aquino came o mio que tener porque
montego Tabata Siriano produce in test a
compile seguro meriva t-rex Todd yatta
receipt I said a toy ponies so this is
the 20th anniversary of pokemon as I
think many of you know and when thinking
about the future of Pokemon I've decided
that I would be the producer on this
title and also and pass over the
director role over 20 or more here for
Pokemon Sun and Moon
compaq ok tu no estás on no ed
extra-base masta amor tomos mosquito on
Kaiba t-rex tato esta gente nitez adios
so I'm shigemori from Game Freak and I
was the director on this game overseeing
the entire development of it thank you
so much for joining us today I know you
brought some art assets we can take a
look at to introduce folks to the
Pokemon moon Pokemon Sun collection but
first we've actually got some video
footage that you bought for us so folks
watching if you sit tight we're actually
gonna get that cued up for you so you
can take a look
you
alright so there's a lot for us to talk
about just some footage there the first
thing I'd like to actually ask you is if
you could tell us a bit more about the
background of why you went with sun and
moon as the titles for these games my
mother is jose Akiko Allison IOT
analytics and escaped no my mother sues
Nemo Santo Nino multi-tenancy tema y de
a Ocho Toshi team una mosca hi I know
what I said no no son de Tico not cute
too Tony on Mikey manoa attacks on you
okay let's get more muscle mother day mr
sun equivalent estatoe ta Keo guard
Massimo Otto not a kimono Tirana pet I
odo skip tian hua nahi suna putas es una
mujer collins neck campobasso no mas ma
oh my oh Rico Milioti kini oh no miss a
[ __ ] tight y muy mas que mas te traje
canal no no sample moon do you know type
of issues so there's a variety of
meanings behind the titles but one of
the main things is that for example for
here on earth obviously the Sun really
is the source of all life on this planet
and in the same way in the Pokemon world
it's also the source of life on the
planet and the moon also affects all of
our lives here as well with this game we
really wanted to express this kind of
feeling of a reason really teeming with
life so he felt that sun and moon would
be an appropriate title for the games I
think especially thinking about these
big elemental forces Sun and the moon we
also need to talk about those
legendaries that are on the packaging
because I think folks are going to
really want to hear a little bit more
about what they can expect from this
pokemon Toyota matzke no sonzai I wasn't
even nothing like I was gonna call a
[ __ ] cuidense it's on a pokemons CT hi
how much dimmer a monster so this nano
son de Tico Tsuruga Rio de Matteo no
shisha the feminine ordenar a la conoci
sharpest a style Allah tailenders get
more my momma Dee hey Johnny ha
monogatari see tiny hannity conquista
could miss Jeannie not a Muslim dead hey
Thomas amini state big [ __ ] not to my
mouth so in the game the legends say
that solga leo and luna la are the
emissaries of the sun in the moon
respectively and the these two legendary
Pokemon actually the kind of playa
unique for all the time to the story in
a unique way that we really haven't done
was pairs of legendary Pokemon before us
I think fans would be really excited
about it I think these are a really
interesting spiritual element that we
get in these games i will talk about
that too much epics and were saving some
surprises but on the subject of
legendaries I know you recently had an
event in Taiwan where you revealed some
news about another legendary Pokemon
folks remember from X Y and what they
might expect from that Pokemon in these
games and we can maybe you talk about
that a little bit to the dance is
[ __ ] on how nicely a message is
chewed on tywanda much hi ya XO enters
the audience is [ __ ] when he's if not
used to too much to help yourselves at
home hi Tanisha Thomas tomorrow Moscow
so no no yo no cheap-ass antoje guard
800 no perfect jose ortega massaman
toshio sato hey yo se la se la de mas
together mo mo kaya no one watching our
demo at Exeter tell yo mama no point of
an optimist so let's i guard pokemon the
gleam of the legendary pokemon said
appeared in originally 4x plus it has
recently showed off their the 10-percent
form complete form in the games and
these Pokemon will are these forms will
appear in Pokemon Sun and Moon kind of a
in a special way that I think that
you'll be excited about they look so
cool and actually here since we're
looking a little bit of a little region
in the background as probably a good
chance to talk it may be a little bit
more detail about the Aloha region and
what players can maybe expect their
motto conquer a volcano a vagina auto de
gijón CT motto mustard on achieve
another party Moscow she
so des Nieto Punk I know Rajee Honan des
cadeaux yokomo dicks totes Naga tiene
mucho nachos nah no de hecho hecho who
you know porque manga sunday vemos ahora
todo na milein discreet amor ya na mano
you write the show hey you know Joe the
modulo kumi same ad open it aphrodite
you neyo comedic wonder my xmas so the
alot of region as you can see it's made
up these four islands it has a man-made
island as well but it's really this
region that's just like a teeming with
life and that's actually behind the name
of the region itself we have this a
meaning of kind of region over like a
miraculous regional flowing was this
life force that can support all this
different life and i think is really
interesting since it's not connected to
any of the other regions you've got this
really interesting area of isolation and
we're seeing all these pokemon that
nobody's ever run into before and it's
almost kind of feels like the Galapagos
Islands where you've got this really
interesting remote area where all these
other creatures are popping up a new but
new Pokemon in a really cool environment
as well it's less it's not up tonight
okay that's not an exact weight on that
a kata ma Phoenix I'm told us Angelica
not even often that's good so there's a
city cafe yeah got some cool things to
see in there yeah I've been playing it
working very hard to look at it
something that's going off course not
time you think it will not wait door
okay and actually since we're talking
about new Pokemon is there anything more
that you can tell our viewers about the
three starters that they'll be choosing
from in this game come get a man my size
of a partner something no one else can
put any constant ain't it oh [ __ ] they
saw this anymore do not some type more
coin just get more Punk a token yet
rookie me 30 finished it's good to
mastema a bottle chiller tight oh c'mon
hey it'll not a poor Widow Kira kawaii
kon Ariana design states great things so
of course they're all very cute but one
of the things I really focused on these
three in particular is making their
movements really cute when the
representative the game like for example
in battle and other parts in the game
you see them moving around and the
really cute can't make you want to reach
out and touch them almost
tato know Perico say Conestoga meet a
mock of Acharya see Tessa in te toca ha
no typo no Cara moksha type data going I
te toma de semana para estar dino Morea
no I saw no sign be cured eyes in esteem
and another thing we always pay
attention to with our really focus on
with the initial put money you choose
your partner is making them kind of
universally relatable so people from
around the world will be able to look at
these Pokemon and relate with them very
easily and also very easy to understand
like for example the grass type Pokemon
is going to be green obviously so being
careful with the colors i think what
folks have seen already from the
animations that we've shown in a little
bit of video footage we've been able to
share they they have a lot of
personality i actually pick pop leo
because i'm a hardcore water starter fan
my first was a squirtle and I'm stuck
with them but I've been having a great
time so far name I'm looking forward to
seeing what other folks pic when i get
into the starters as well did he got me
in on the video he's the type of karachi
maria holic don't hope so because I take
another 90 make another one inserting
actually what you talked about with the
the design of the starter pokemon i
think they also really fit nicely in
with the kind of tropical climate and
environment we've got and i know that's
something that you worked in with the
design of the player characters as well
time around pokemon minamino kenichi is
80 knots Emma any mucho porque Momo
soukous or idiotic and a token Cano
desmosedici sorry tiered Marasco so desu
nee on a periodic I cooney Tino shogun
through
machi holders me hey okay so Dominic
honor it case only steam us so yeah
obviously the region this time the
climate there is extremely warm so we
wanted to make sure that the characters
the designs were more lightly dressed
and they may be other designs have in
the past I think fans will notice the
proportions are different especially we
get into gameplay in a couple seconds
here they're gonna see it's still
different how they're used to seeing
their characters in the game matano
lanka sudan amato cheeky presidents go
to tahoe is no soda snare a no Yuriko
watson account Tommy don't a social at
the Mustang okay so yeah we are we
change the proportions tend to be more
realistic we really want to kind of
increase the sense of immersion and I
think to see that and when we get into
the game yeah I don't know if I can talk
about this yet but sharp-eyed viewers
probably noticed that both of those
pieces of art there was an interesting
bracelet that the players were wearing I
don't know if I can probably can't talk
about that just yet sorry to my house my
car sales given time middle to the toy
store we did well let me take a model
skipped it in this girl party much for
later time maybe we could talk about but
I think we've probably kept folks in
anticipation long enough so Terry I you
want to jump in and try some game
excited for this must didnt know
something we go yeah so i just want to
mention as we get into gameplay here
this game is still in development so
folks everything you see here might not
be exactly what you're going to see in
the final release of the game but i
think we can give you a really good
sense of what the game is going to look
and feel like as we get started
oscillation or family
I Iran policy so no live demo opener no
hazama today ha no Donna porque mamá
daruka tiene mucho chica hot scoop and a
bouquet of roses it comes tonight just
ok the first time for us to show a
pokemon game at the stage and
development can be a live gameplay so
not really sure exactly what we're going
to encounter in this we may see some all
new Pokemon have another field before oh
my fingers crossed that be really cool
actually as we get started here so
defined the more you son can you tell us
a little bit about the story in the
background of what's going on right now
in the game Michael college shalinka not
obscene vanishes so this minute oh she's
in quality adoro te gusta que bajar 80 s
a tentative cake on ksl any moscow
sistemas de sighs oh no porque mas de
amor at emmas makara Iggy tanto como tu
digas hi sorry no day so pony Makoto
qualities so at this point in the game
it's a little bit slightly into it but
it's a player actually had just moved to
the Aloha region the other day and one
day previous to where we are in the game
yet received his first partner Pokemon
sort of adventure and right now we're
actually on the way to a neighboring
town which is a festival no I think here
it is a little bit okay oh then I got my
pokemon very much funny Oh Liddy Valdez
yeah I don't like Sonia what kind of
2004 came home or did it get high so as
you can see in the oh Allah region
obviously it's not just new Pokemon
their unique leola region but from other
regions you see Pokemon pocono Serena
todo porque Montego no mascara goes
psychomotor know Karina guy so Nico
okay well no you don't need the purple
tie against antique here in battle you
see the trainer is actually standing
behind the Pope the pokemon in the
battles we really want to express this
feeling of the trainer always being with
his or her pokemon let's talk about that
in a little more detail here because I
feel like there's so much that you've
done with them the way the battle looks
in this game to make it feel really
intense and really immersive we're going
to talk a little bit more about that
with what you did with the lighting and
the dynamic camera angles here both of
you call talk on me to see how much
what's up hyper codec was great safavieh
tamagotchi got to take a yoga no more
anniversaries so this mess ha no todos
you can you take a Giga not often a
static over cinema high production was
me so yeah there's some cool lighting
effects that we're doing here where the
forgettable the shadow you see it's in
the evening right now so it's a bit
longer but depending on the time of day
that the lighting will kind of a affect
the mood of the battle
I think here at Terry's kind of staying
still for a second to let us see how the
camera is moving around and this is
something it'll just happen for you if
you're staying still in the battle for a
moment and you really get a good chance
to get a look at these Pokemon and the
area that you're in in the environment
not quiet down or get motilium at the
optical image girl and one muscle coming
and how it's all nice people I get back
for quick coffee comin in without this
week or bucket apenas in the city on the
phone okay coming up so we dynamics up
in your new ski see he's still editing
so there's definitely some cool to kind
of make the camera feel really dance
dynamic and the battles December and
actually as the Terra get started in the
battle here but sometimes we could talk
a little bit more about the different
changes you make the battle interface I
know there's a lot of that's really
interesting which makes the game really
accessible to new players maybe this is
the first Pokemon game but it's also i
think really satisfying as someone who's
played a lot of Pokemon games it just it
feels really good the changes that
you've made here quick little moppet
illinois apophis's insignificant no
interface miss you tonight pangolin i go
in choke on the scale do you think of
items so this new Maccon 502 more 80 she
said to not become sits in a little edie
famous that a personal information both
are valid skidmore the gel touch to the
soul in mass so no matter i don't know i
got it estimated [ __ ] are you need nap
days so for example yeah we really try
to focus on making it really accessible
and easy to understand something moves
there Terry just press a little I button
are the icon that's on the move and you
can go into a detailed explanation of
what that moves actually those
I think it's been so helpful they're
just so many pokemon that you have to
keep in mind now as you're battling it's
so nice to be able to pull it up and if
maybe you don't quite remember what the
King does being able to pop it up really
faster it's like you don't have to use
that information but it may be your
memory cause you're so used to read me
that it's so nice to be able to pull
that up and take a look I took all my
don't give tennis stop it ah slowly
start getting a hair over you mark it or
biggie bummer for a Pettis did when I go
get dog kappa late my phone that don't
they okay I'll tell you exactly you can
see there's the you can tap on the 2d
Pokemon I to Pike on this up the touch
screen and see how its parameters
actually just got changed because of the
effect of it and I move one where they
didn't boo avoid the neck take a nap i'm
just going to quit each time we do I
thought you so as it just said like a
lot of things you have to keep in your
head yet to remember before now
visualize on the interface itself
yeah let's see how this battle goes are
you planning on trying to capture I'm
gonna begin my quest attach them all
okay it's gonna tell my kids don't like
this yeah good you can do it so um just
to bring up real quickly for folks who
maybe haven't played a pokemon game
before battling pokemon is really at the
core of what the series is all about
you're going out into the world with
your Pokemon battling oh this is the
most stressful moment come on but it's a
really interesting game if you're
interested in battle and strategy and a
collecting all these really interesting
pokemon that you meet hopefully a little
bit good job it was nice there to seeing
how the level up change 2000 live it up
the main system onto the car it is oh
and this is actually something that we
should talk about as well q tell our
viewers a little bit more about what
they're seeing on the upper screen very
much at the zoo control of certain put
hey Chico contigo so gravity a token ka2
Sukarno a toss of Interstate we made a
clean arteriosus or create columns
master the honesty ramón starborn antes
que como estas aqui space na frente de
baisemeaux schemata porque mono ass in
Cabo kasuri tomo OS kucera piatto porque
no te creo como si ni
uniden sistemas y no por donde por que
manera de atacama in agra [ __ ] pirate
scum I just a [ __ ] not the wings so one
of the things we wanted to do with the
pokédex this time was really encourage
players to again really want to catch
them all really fill up the pokédex and
one way we've done those you can see
there's the lady by disqus registered
but next to it is a white polka ball
icon what that does that indicates
there's an empty space which means that
either has an evolution or maybe there's
another Pokemon out there that kind of
forms a pair with it it's a little kind
of encourage players really want to fill
up that empty space go out and search
and you know catch all different types
of Pokemon and kind of complete the
pokédex yes especially exciting I think
when you find one and there's lots of
white pokeballs and you're just like oh
ok so that's a cool can I talk shows oh
lets you get a toxic you sure we got
whatever sim pokemon youngest so you pop
him on this it's a la una causa
Scottsdale take Monica ethics 240
coconut Jeff do pokemon lassie resume so
as you can see this is the new pokemon
called young juice it's always hungry so
it's always getting hungry and then so
it's looking for food but whenever is
hungry it also it gets very aggressive I
love its face I thought the best part
though I feel like to just throw it a
bag of chips with this place ok I give
each other oh man Oh getting close there
let's come out in this come on you're
probably able to catch in this one we're
on our way oh good luck that's two down
me [ __ ] man yeah yeah this is not like
the most stressful seconds in any
Pokemon players life oh I think this
will give us a chance to maybe take a
look at the pokédex so we've got a new
Pokemon to check out
we've got some interesting changes
coming to the pokédex in this game you
tell us a bit more about what fans can
expect from the new pokedex makan
katsucon otouto uh no haha kinda late
other skeletons given from all month ok
Gandhi 3 which is multi master master so
this a token Kyoto muzu canto y Monod
arias 80 condo Ruto's candy scream oh ok
modes camaro Yoho Cretaro ha marbach and
it's agreed upon a given do photoset
Achrekar who can chill in chapel dos
segredos to come so actually one of the
new things in this game so we have this
item called Rotom pokedex and Rotom kind
of inhabits your pokedex and actually
helps you your adventure so it'll tell
you information about Pokemon that you
really want to catch or give you tips
about how to catch pokemon and also got
kind of guide you on your adventure
where you should go X for example so it
serves as a really cool supportive
function Iman 7 inguk really disco
that's when you total who's gonna Heidi
so right here actually we're still
really early in the game we don't have
the road on pokedex to the touch screen
is just black on the bottom but you'll
get it later and here actually this is a
great chance if we just like take a look
quick circle around we can show off not
only the trainer's proportions but also
the the movement is a little bit
different than what my previous pokemon
games expected tossing a cada una de
mucho de dono Thank You cousin be tomato
so this fellow cop I on Okan kaya Farini
Jr who kiriona screaming stay with me so
yeah you can move around free fall in a
lot look at this time again oh oh and we
need to tell players what's going on
here go to point of seeing the the
shadow duelist 800ma escano character
for Monsta below- miss Kay Kay Monterey
nervous desi Simmons trainin OCA miss
Cochran Ione ma to get it quotes and
King Joker are worse things so you see
that lady over there on the girl
throwing up hook it all up and down and
so she's a pokemon trainer and what
she's obviously gonna try and battle you
but what that kind of shadow that
appears on the screen indicates is that
there's a she's going to challenge you
to a battle so it kind of increases this
sense of tension though you're gonna
have to go into a battle and indicates
that to the player so I can either avoid
or actually battle jack will both
enlisted to go sake to go I think
battle at that moment where to public
glaring at each other make ready to
fight come on people but it is really
nice if you're in a position where maybe
you're trying to get somewhere really
quickly or your Pokemon aren't in great
shape right now you don't want to fight
it's nice to have that second where you
can avoid it before you just kind of
stumble yourself into a battle just like
poking a macgregor took a few things I
get the Gilman suck it is not sure this
me yeah that's right I think I so we can
see here we're seeing the other trainer
as well and it's really nice actually
just to get such a good look at the
Pokemon proportions alongside their
trainers before Katrina oh no i do not
own a download button didn't know epic
or size ago Pokemon go sighs computer
thank you sorry my solo a pipe or Karina
hey Rico Tonio tioga ND steady no home
kanata receipt oh man yeah certainly one
of the new things i think by having the
trainers in battle if you mentioned it
really gives you that sense of scale
nothing from the experience I've had at
the office playing this game it's really
gonna surprise people when they take a
look at just how big and small certain
pokemon are when they're actually
standing right next to them my favorite
up you know if you've gone what can I
got the boom all good but she saw
something need a epic I'm on the [ __ ]
phone oh except don't operate Oh Trina
go to Nizhny loco-motion no Christians
into a born on I got a debate oka okay
Mon this is yoga's see pasado con aceite
Monica come I can't see PSAT I mean yeah
it's at the post editor the trainer is
being represented in full 3d this time
they all have unique motions and
reactions for example how they throw
their poker ball or their reaction when
they lose for example I can we don't
listen they just got an item there
I think there might be some more folks
we can battle up here father we got
trained about the time I didn't I not
call psyche as we're walking around eh
eh i'm hoping folks who are watching or
listening with the volume up so they
could hear the music in this area i just
found its really great how it feels it
feels fits in with the tropical
environment still telling me all the
time hey quarter to the ones go long go
see what ideas man i mean having a green
you need about the country I look like a
fiesta collection all right so yeah give
is making oh yeah this is me another
gallery looks like and we can see as
Terry's battling here with how the
battle interface is set up it's really
easy to just get super involved in the
battle to to whatever extent you want to
be you've got all this information at
your fingertips it's not that you have
to look at it all but so nice that if
there's anything that you need to check
on you can do it so quickly and then you
still feel really immersed in the battle
rapper sourcing and about an interface
here for you don't know jo hoga why not
can we keep missing mom you try to do a
touchdown state where Joe horse whinnies
up in the air for Vinny so Desmond Tyco
pot roast it a mark Whittle Donna Jo
tied up and get oka Matsui to go to a
zoo for your phone cousin to the door
ashish a team or not conoco bouquet
bathroom Matt works guess when I cannot
say of course really there's a lot of
depth to the battles but you don't have
for example beginners for example maybe
don't want to or they won't remember a
lot of these different status changes
what up you can really quickly check on
the state and see how things have
changed I'll say I love young gooses
painting she don't mean to call you
sneeze money a little bigger scale our
DNA to skip okay Mona sk Domo hai
achieve yo-yo judo crentist a cure
attack toh yaad AATA Pokemon des neige
there's a pic a pic called the wood
poker are assuming the wait I can speak
for that so the setting of this pokemon
is that it can actually text een x + 1
seconds it's got very fast beat judo
python talks to them did you okay that's
it so yeah watching its animation as its
it's got very bird-like movements as its
kind of touching its head so i decided i
think that the level of detail you guys
have put into all the pokemon animations
in this game is really fantastic i'm
also the new book super famicom i
accepted it Duncan a programmable how do
you down a confidential listening could
be 0 y 0 Maha no one of your new friends
is ready to help us out as a good chance
to mention actually we did find a
pokeball earlier as we're walking around
one class all my items to help you out
along the way that can help you heal up
your Pokemon and yeah those high-risk
garlic because of you the whole thing
that's come out the electrons hi rishta
can't you leave I got a little letter
that though ma where they live it up it
baby don't know almost another one wait
haha yeah note I go meet his name let me
definitely another I think one of the
things really makes Pokemon a front yeah
it's kind of like sense of tension here
so do we have anything we can give up
Liotta I think it's time to go oh well
sort of you ready after they meet I'm
climacool cop so now we'll just run to
the swim hi look what I got niguel
Oh Jung Geun oh yeah hey there you're
gonna heal up after this yeah we'll get
healed up we're get hill though I think
the project to the festival cuz that's
not to give too much away but there's
there's more fighting a new music or
fight I was like Obama talked about the
other day so it's kinda like up dude so
actually as we come into the this area
here we're gonna be meeting several
different characters that our viewers
maybe aren't familiar with would you
mind just giving us quick introduction
to the mythology characteristic is a
little joke is the monitoring Scott hey
so this veto in Madeira tonito chakra
sonic scream oh oh no character the
heart of you can appease me hey Johnny
Popp ok Momo credito you character the
people you know my todo esta mas this is
hollow I think it's been revealed
already in a video that we released but
it's really strong trainer on this
island and it's actually the guy who
gives you your first partner pokemon in
your adventure suit or knowledge is a
very strong trainer on this island
heddo Koopa hotels nato na na do Matsuri
tienes que toca not o.o mata de Sin Cara
kindness this is how you're about to
battle him actually as part of this
festival yeah hey quickly this okay
Monica say this punker it was a no kinky
or stay till you have a seat and let's
professor Kukui right there and the
white lab coat is a professor who
specializes in researching pokemon move
select their attacks and such I think
based on the fan response i've seen he
is quickly becoming the most dreamy
professor thank you for looking you know
a little longer dds net ok mon autre
nada ni ng screamo como mission evoking
through calculus and that's a lily
behind you there she's the assistant of
Professor Kukui and she's not a pokemon
trainer but she'll join you on your
adventure throughout the story and
sharp-eyed viewers may have noticed her
yourself bag is fantastic say to the
colors are all day to my picture the
King any money come on the horn not go
OD much thank you where did I get on
there go you gotta get me but I think
it's time we go into the vessel battle
sort of all method in the Buffett hi you
must go I think it's gonna be really
interesting for fans of the series to
see this battle and in the space the way
that pokemon and Pokemon battles are
integrated into the culture in these
islands is really interesting and you
get these amazing battle spaces where
other folks are gathering around and
watching you guys fight pocono epical
ningun Osaka anyway Pokemon Pokemon
battles on a monocoque or not is a shock
any given us this week Texas na mano de
Nova super starting on seppuku you a
scholarship or Pasadena weekend i'm
addicted 80 this in a mock hecho con que
con o Matsu in antes que tomó a stenotab
Adachi oh ma evil Turkish rediske
Martinez a toccata tony kanal tari
vecino mega volcano gemalto is Serena
things so in this and this particular
festival actually this is kind of a
celebration or a way to kind of kick
both you and how's adventures to kind of
travel across the island so it's kind of
a ritual in this society and that folks
may have noticed there is a another
thing we can't really talk about too
much but just to mention top of cocoa
birthday attention that name you don't
like that can you know to come on here
we talk to you by the better oh and so
how about a peach you look adorable yeah
kawaii this man from the muck and Ione
leave it to me Marcus the girls aged and
here we can see see what he's done
checking different effect pollinate they
are doing a quarter Cuttino connaught
pinoy cat emoji venga mario home here in
this hotel on Ben is where you can see
both your change status changes as well
as the opponent setting and really see
what's going on in the battle so looking
at this tropical environment i'm really
hoping that you guys were able to pull
off some business trips it's a nice
tropical locations maybe it's for
research its work just have to go okay
i'll go pop mean a movie set they don't
go epic or can't you mukti decor you
don't know taking a bash on the kick it
up Johnny ahsoka haha so this is me much
finna get close Micah has no subsidy or
assignee how I need this menu do it on a
more cheerful me tell you it is I Nemo
you guys had it at each stage so yeah we
actually took as the staff the
development staff that came for quick
quick trips to Hawaii to really do some
research and we definitely you'd already
had to kind of reflect in the gaming I
checking miss my boss that I need to do
that kept for this to really get this
segment I really would you go that way
okay I was taking me throw some in the
apical how I need to get about this
contest yet
oh well that's one now because my sire
so I start with the icons of the battle
started I think how has one more Pokemon
to go how much you got oh you Pig it is
man hey you and your skill nice oh she
was stronger hmm they receive one of the
other new starters yeah me nan desu kedo
mo ito y que je samo m/s optimist a
track auto de cine Eddie Connecticut re
ok muah DOTA Garko Cassavetes Katya
novick Ariana interfacing captains so at
this point in the story you see how has
Lytton which is another one of the first
pokémon you can choose your adventure
but you've actually encountered a you
battled against him and his Lytton once
in the story and so once you've input
once on the moon once you've battled the
Pokemon once the next time you battle it
you'll get information on your move list
about which moves or effective which
ones aren't Time Matters hey I know
goodbye fixie visited lots of them
period download so just explaining that
yeah it's super face yeah whatever
they'll stick with that one yeah sure
she's had a mohawk are ya see whose game
but just coming back to make it all very
easy to understand for beginners all the
games oh never Lee is so nice to have
that information still hold up i'll do
it i'll study month net i think
especially when you're trying to catch
more pokemon you're like okay I actually
maybe don't want to be super effective
right now and you kind of Wiggles
Pokemon down so being able to remember
maybe you want to use your weaker
attacks sometimes just I kinda get the
details to that point the latex to come
as a textaholic or cocoa butter
container you hold it all hit me I can
let us make gonna go home oh yeah that's
my stuff I love what a good sport how is
about losing 2 he's just come okay so I
don't think we can go too much further
in the game play because we're going to
start giving away story elements that we
don't want to show folks yet but you did
bring another video for us to take a
look at that has a new gameplay mode all
that I don't think folks have seen
before kono saki apogee keep race
marathon doma story 0 neta bikini
I wasted two days on Obama dictate right
Radhika another school hajimete a con
que todo at RCC modo you know Pokemon y
comunicación toes cerritos Ted mama de
co ty siento cuando Pitino hottest antes
que domo kun kaya Sarah Nicotra sick
attached Eden oh man oh man pot or TMO
Noah pues dismiss a pattern oh yeah they
won't stay though with a pokemon series
obviously communic using it as a kind of
a communication tool facilitating that
communication between players is always
been one of the things we've really
focused on with the game so trading and
battling between players of course this
time that's no different we've got an
all new multiplayer battle mode which
we're calling the battle royale all
right well let's see if our crew can
load that up for us and we can check out
this treatable okay so I think it
started here you tell us a little bit
about what